okay we were speaking earlier about
killing grandma to save the stock market
essentially the calculation that Donald
Trump seems increasingly comfortable
making and erring on the side of the
stock market instead of Grandma Texas
lieutenant governor Dan Patrick says
that many grandparents like him are
willing to die to save the economy for
their grandchildren and if nothing else
this pandemic has really exposed how
incompetent and immoral or amoral so
many people in positions of power are so
now I bring you a segment from FoxNews
propagandist Tucker Carlson's program
where Dan Patrick makes is this the a
patriotic argument is that what he's
calling it that that it's a patriotic
case for letting it rip
living in fear of is what's happening to
this country and you know
Tucker no one reached out to me and said
as a senior citizen are you willing to
take a chance on your survival in
exchange for keeping the America that
all America loves for your children and
grandchildren and if that's the exchange
I'm all-in
and that doesn't make me Noble or brave
or anything like that I just think there
are lots of grandparents out there in
this country like me I have six
grandchildren that what we all care
about and what we love more than
anything are those children and I want
to you know live smart and and see
through this but I don't want the whole
country to be sacrificed and I and
that's what I see I've talked to
hundreds of people Tucker and just in
the last week and making calls all the
time and and everyone says pretty much
the same thing that we can't lose our
whole country we're having an economic
collapse I'm also a small businessman
understand it and I talked with business
people all the time Tucker and and I'm
so my I'm just my heart is lifted
tonight by what I heard the president
say because we can do more than you know
one thing at a time we can do two things
so you know my message is that let's get
back to work let's get back to living
let's be smart about it and those of us
who are 70 plus we'll take care of
ourselves
that's a so-called pro-life Republic
saying let's let the grandparents die so
that we don't sacrifice the economy by
which they really don't mean the economy
they mean the stock market and the
funniest or the craziest or sort of the
most tragic thing about all of this is
that he and Trump they're all talking
about let's go back to doing stuff 30 or
50 states roughly have done nothing or
almost nothing in other words they want
30 states to go from having done nothing
anyway to continuing to do nothing while
the other 20 states including places
that are significant hot spots would
have to take a would have to choose a
path that would lead to significantly
more death it's only been like a week
where I'm like eight days in now to the
self-isolation and we've already got
Trump and others saying let's let more
old folks die in order for the stock
market to recover in order to not take
as big of a GDP hit as what we are in
undoubtedly going to take in order to
prevent as big of an unemployment
increase as we clearly are going to see
on April 3rd when the March unemployment
numbers are announced it's essentially a
death panel remember back when Sarah
Palin and other Republicans when
Obamacare was being negotiated
they said Obamacare has death panels
where politicians get to decide if you
live or die if what you need does or
doesn't get paid for now at the time we
pointed out this is absurd we already
have death panels which are called
insurance companies insurance companies
already decide is this treatment or that
treatment considered medically necessary
does this treatment or that treatment
get covered by insurance we already had
what is it and continue to have what is
essentially a death panel but the more
absurd part of this is they're
essentially saying we've decided some
old people have to die it's a death
panel to save the economy by which they
mean the stock market how is this going
to play by the way with Fox News's own
disproportionately older audience I mean
in all seriousness I'm wondering
about that and then moreover you know
lieutenant governor of Texas Dan Patrick
if he wants to sacrifice himself maybe
there's something to talk about
but he's deciding for other people he's
deciding we should sacrifice lots of
grandparents for the sake of the economy
and the the the economy for our
grandchildren as he says it's actually
almost cultist surrender your life to
the Trump stock market which now by the
way is a net decline Donald Trump's
major accomplishment as he claimed for
the first three years of his presidency
was the stock market now all along we
knew that stock market growth under
Obama had actually been better stronger
bigger than under Donald Trump now he
doesn't have that and you've got people
like dan Patrick saying I would
sacrifice myself and many grandparents
would volunteering essentially unknown
and faceless grandparents as he knows
them or doesn't know them in order to
save the economy meaning pump the stock
market so Trump can claim that he did
something for the country while he was
president it sounds very much like the
opposite of small government deciding to
sacrifice grandma for the stock market
but of course it seems that that is no
longer the priority of small government
conservatives today's program is made
possible in part by our sponser identity
guard giving my audience 33% off when
you use the link underneath this video
we talk about data breaches on the show
we talk about them too often because
they happen too often and a lot of
people underestimate how likely they are
to become victims of identity theft as a
result of these breaches that take place
and it's a nightmare the average
identity theft victim loses more than
thirteen hundred dollars and six months
of their life trying to clean the mess
up it's no joke but what identity guard
does is monitor the dark web and alert
you any time your social security number
credit card numbers account numbers or
other personal information are detected
in places where criminals share this
stuff with each other online they also
detect red flags like changes to your
bank
accounts or your credit score's and
you'll get an alert as quickly as in a
few seconds if you do become a victim of
identity theft identity guard sets you
up with a dedicated support team who
will take what would normally be a very
stressful situation and turn it into
something as easy as possible to resolve
and you'll be covered for up to a
million dollars of reimbursement for
stolen funds identity guard plans start
at just $8.99 a month but the David
Pakman show audience will instantly get
33% off by using the link underneath
this video you'll also get access to
identity guards browser extension which
protects you from phishing attempts
unsecured websites other types of
attacks just while you're browsing
around online it takes just a few
minutes to set up an account you give
them a few pieces of info about yourself
and you're good to go the identity theft
headaches are often completely avoidable
if you have a service that's protecting
you from it and will help you to deal
with it if something were to happen an
identity guard is the most trusted one
out there it's already affordable but
you'll save an extra 33% when you use my
link which I've put in the description
right underneath this video